[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Today,
we're here with Luv, CEO
from Techolution, and we're
very excited to explore
how Techolution uses Anthos.
But first, Luv,
thanks for joining us.
Can you tell us a bit more
about what Techolution does,
and what it's like to be
a Google Cloud Partner?
LUV TUSIDAS: Thank you, Mark,
for having me on the show.
Techolution is a next gen
digital transformation company,
and we're really proud
to be at the heart
of the digital transformation
that's happening in the world
right now.
Data is power, right?
But when you have too much
data, it can turn into noise
and paralyze a business.
What we do as a company,
we leverage the power
of cloud, specifically
Google Cloud, and AI
to help businesses
go from reactive
to proactive and predictive.
As a Google Cloud
Partner, we specialize
in Kubernetes, helping companies
from strategy, architecture,
implementation, and then managed
services-- the full lifecycle
of a Kubernetes experience.
And most recently, we've been
very involved with Anthos
since it went GA back
in April because we
have a deep expertise in
the hybrid cloud space,
and we work with various
different hybrid cloud
technologies.
And we find Anthos to
be one of the best.
And we're on a mission right now
to share the benefits of Anthos
with the world.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
It's great to hear
about how Techolution
can help these companies
adopt a very digital strategy.
So can you tell us a bit
more about, specifically,
how Anthos helps enable that?
LUV TUSIDAS: Yeah.
I just want to take a moment
to look at what is Anthos.
Anthos is essentially
Kubernetes.
And all of the
bells and whistles
around Kubernetes
on the Google Cloud
being packaged so
that you can bring it
to your data center,
on-prem, or any other cloud.
And you can have
a truly flexible
build-once,
deploy-anywhere experience.
Now plain Kubernetes
also somewhat does that,
but Anthos is enterprise grade.
It allows you to do that
very, very efficiently.
There are a UI tools and
automation built into it
for the enterprise.
We work with-- mostly we're
seeing companies that are
heavily regulated in
banking, health care, gov,
and a little bit of telco, where
they cannot move and modernize
their entire application
directly to public cloud
for those reasons
that I mentioned.
So Anthos is really a
great solution for them
to start modernizing in place
or their cloud of choice
and then to be able to
slowly, as it proves itself,
to be able to move some of the
workloads to the public cloud.
And Anthos allows
them to do that
in a very efficient
and very rapid manner.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, it makes sense
that the value prop
there exists in being
able to, like you
said, write once,
deploy in multiple places,
especially as environments
are becoming both a combination
of hybrid and multi-cloud.
The ability to scale it
out there is very valuable.
Can you share a little bit more
about some of the customers
that you've worked with and
how Anthos has helped them?
LUV TUSIDAS: Sure.
We're seeing a lot of traction
working with customers
in health care and finance.
I'll take health
care as an example.
Let's say a SaaS
provider, who's serving
two hospitals and other
health care institutions,
where they're
providing software that
ends up recording and storing
a lot of patient data.
That's very sensitive data,
very highly regulated.
So typically, those would run
on-prem or on data center,
but now the cloud is
very mature, very secure,
and sometimes more secure
than on-prem data center.
But there are a lot of larger
organizations in the health
care space that you, A, may
not be comfortable with running
their patient data on
somebody else's public cloud
and shared with other
tenants, or due to regulations
or whatever the reason
may be, they're not
comfortable with that.
So the SaaS provider, by
building and modernizing
the application base and
their data on a Kubernetes
Anthos-based solution,
they're able to make a choice.
They could serve some customers
on GCP, where their application
runs, or they could, with
the click of a button,
deploy that same
solution on-prem
to their larger enterprise
organizations that
want to run on-prem.
So that's one case study.
Similar case studies
we're seeing in finance.
But the one that's
very interesting,
a trend that I've seen emerge,
is in the telco sector.
As 5G becomes a reality,
we're seeing an emergence
of a lot of IoT, smart
city type of solutions
that's generating a lot of
data in real time over 5G.
And the kind of data and
compute that they need
requires an edge-based
solution, because even
though the throughput is
faster, sending all the data
on the cloud and
get a decision back
may not be fast enough
in this new world.
So Anthos actually has been
a really great solution
to bring some of that compute
on the edge local level,
and telcos are building
solutions around that.
And then for other services, you
could go to the public cloud.
And the true benefit of
Anthos in a deployment
like that, it's
very large scale.
And managing all of the
nodes across, let's say,
all the deployments out there--
all the cities and public
cloud--
can be though very difficult
without a product like Anthos.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
It's great to hear
about where Anthos is actually
solving these problems
and how technology is
continuing to increase,
and Anthos is helping
make that manageable.
Luv, thank you so much for
coming on and telling us
a bit more about it.
LUV TUSIDAS: Thank you, Mark,
for having me on the show.
It was a pleasure.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Absolutely.
If you'd like to learn
more about Techolution,
you can visit techolution.com.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks for watching, and stay
tuned for more great episodes
of Stack Chat.